all right welcome back everyone
okay so happy Halloween I was hoping to
see more people dressed up but I guess
I'm not so that's fine okay so what I
want to do today is talk a little bit
about numerical integration before
jumping into how to solve
ODU's computationally okay now I don't
want to downplay numerical integration
it's very important it's actually like a
really important thing to know how to do
I don't want to spend too much time on
it because it's very similar to
numerical differentiation and this is
not like a full numerical analysis class
okay so I'm gonna hit the highlights
we're gonna know how to program it and
what the basic error scalings are for
different methods and that's it so
hopefully we'll get through this quickly
and get to a numerical integration of
Odie's okay so last time we saw just
like with numerical differentiation we
can take some function f of X and we can
chop it up into a bunch of finite
intervals and we can approximate the
area under this curve or the integral
using the area of all of these finites
rectangles okay and I'm not going to
write down the formula again because
basically you just add up all these
rectangles it's that simple okay how
accurate do you think this method is
going to be really accurate not very
accurate like what are some feelings
really accurate not very accurate no
basis of comparison okay
so how could this rectangle rule be
inaccurate in what ways might this not
be accurate it can overshoot or
undershoot so notice here every time my
function has a positive slope
I'm undershooting I'm not getting all of
this area there's real area there that
my rectangles are missing and for finite
sized rectangles I will never capture
those and for anytime where my
has a negative slope I'm overshooting
right my rectangles are over predicting
by this amount amounts so fortunately if
I have something like a sine wave they
actually cancel out but so does all of
my other integrals so it's not yeah
these are real errors this is actually a
very problematic method for integration
so let's zoom in a little bit to one of
these rectangles so we're in this
interval X to X plus Delta X we have
some function that's passing through
these two points and my rectangle rule
is approximating the area with this
rectangular area so right off the bat
what's the most natural or intuitive way
that we could possibly improve our
estimate of this area sorry okay so
right now we're saying that this area is
equal to f of X times Delta X this is
the left rectangle now I could also
equally well say okay well I have the
same function but what I'm going to do
is approximate the entire area by this
right rectangle I could do that and this
would say my area is f of X plus Delta x
times Delta X this is my right rectangle
okay so what would I do if I wanted to
get better error properties if I didn't
want to under shoot or overshoot the
actual area quite so badly okay I could
take the average that would be a very
reasonable thing to do and taking the
average has an extremely simple
geometric interpretation okay so what it
really means to take the average of this
so let's just say one half of this Plus
this
equals okay X X plus Delta X so what
we're really doing here is we're taking
our left rectangle and we're adding to
it a triangle of this height okay I mean
if you if you add up this rectangle and
this rectangle you get let's just see
what this looks like you get our short
rectangle plus our tall rectangle but
the tall rectangle has a short rectangle
in it so this equals two short
rectangles Plus this remainder which I
can chop into two triangles okay so when
I take one half of this sum I get one of
my short rectangles plus one of these
triangles okay and that's what I get
here is this trapezoid so this is called
trapezoidal integration this is the
trapezoid rule and this is really what
most people do on a first pass of trying
to integrate a function is they just
apply the trapezoid rule this is kind of
the if it's not the best integration but
it's cheap it's easy it's intuitive and
it actually does a pretty good job
because we're essentially averaging the
left and the right rectangle rules okay
any questions about this so far it's
pretty simple right pretty
straightforward and the formula for this
is really really simple you just say
okay I'm going to integrate I'm going to
take one half of let's say I'm gonna set
I have Delta x over 2 I'm gonna have one
half of Delta x times f of X plus f of X
plus Delta X it's that simple
that's my new area trapezoidal and it's
much more accurate
okay so there's gonna be a couple things
I want to do with numerical
differentiation we talked a lot about
error analysis like how much error do we
have with each of the methods here I'm
just gonna tell you what the errors are
and I'm gonna give you kind of a very
very high-level overview of how you
would confirm that those are the errors
but we're not gonna work through all the
details okay you can do that on your own
there's kind of miscellaneous notes
uploaded on the website if you want to
know how to do this so for the left and
right rectangle we have two types of
error with numerical integration we have
something called local error and
something called global error so any
guesses what I mean by local versus
global error here think about this while
I close the door
okay I'm integrating this function from
some left point to some right point with
a bunch of little rectangles so when I
say local error I mean what is the error
that I accumulate for every little
rectangle that I'm adding up right every
little rectangle has some error
associated with it that's my local error
and my global error is what's the total
error when I add up all of those little
errors right so I'm adding up a bunch of
little rectangles so it turns out that
for the left and the right rectangle
rule my local error for every little
rectangle I add up is like Delta x
squared but how many of these little
rectangles am i adding up like if I have
some function and I have a bunch of
little rectangles spaced Delta X apart
how many of these little rectangles do I
expect to add up
well I start an a and I end it B so my
interval is B minus a and I divide it
into Delta X little pieces so divided by
Delta X so if I wanted to make my local
error smaller I'd make Delta X smaller
right but as I make Delta X smaller I
have more of those little local errors
that I'm adding up 1 over Delta X of
them right I have 1 over Delta X little
rectangles I'm adding up so my global
error is order Delta X I'm adding up 1
over X little rectangles and each of
those 1 over Delta X rectangles has
Delta x squared error so I multiply them
and I get order Delta X global error so
this is no better than finite difference
derivatives right this is still a pretty
poor error scaling okay so trapezoidal
integration has a local error of order
Delta X cubed which gives me what global
error Delta x squared for exactly the
same reason because I'm adding up 1 over
Delta X of these local errors so
trapezoidal is a lot better right for
the same Delta X I get way more accurate
solutions to this integral because I'm
not over shooting or under shooting I'm
kind of averaging out the errors and
getting higher order accurate makes
sense ok these are really easy to code
up especially because there's built-in
MATLAB functions to do trapezoidal
integration so there's a command called
trap Z trapezoidal and this is a nice
code that does trapezoidal integration
so you should you come from earlier with
it I'm trying to think if there's
anything else I want to tell you about
integration there is another method
called the Simpsons rule so how many of
you have heard of Simpsons rule
for yeah okay any anybody remember how
accurate Simpsons rule is SuperDuper
accurate it's way way more accurate than
any of the other schemes
we'll learn so again you could derive
this from scratch but I'm not going to I
really don't want to so if I have my
function and I have three data points x1
x2 let's say it sorry x0 x1 x2 f0 f1 f2
then I can approximate the integral from
x0 to x2 of f of X DX is approximately
equal to Delta x over 3 F naught plus F
plus 4 f1 plus f2
I didn't derive this I'm just telling
you because if you ever come into a
problem where you really need a very
accurate integrator this is a
super-duper accurate integrator in fact
it's plus order Delta X to the fifth
over 90 times the fourth derivative of
my function at some point okay so this
is the thing you'd plug into MATLAB to
approximate this and your error for
every little local approximation is AB
is kind of absurdly small right Delta X
to the fifth over 90 this is a great
scaling of error so this is your local
error and so your global error would be
Delta X to the fourth okay
way better than trapezoidal this is
built into MATLAB to using something
called the quad command how many of you
have used clod before so quad is a
really really cool command except you
don't give it vectors of data you give
it functions so it's a little bit tricky
to use and maybe we'll do that later
the course but the quad command does the
Simpson rule integration
okay we're gonna code up two examples of
integrals using left and right rectangle
and trapezoid and I'm also just gonna
show you a sketch of how you would
predict some of these error terms if you
wanted to or if I asked you to okay oh
by the way I posted it homework for
today it's due next Friday it has four
problems they're not super difficult or
long but again like some of the material
will be in the Monday and the Wednesday
lecture so if you have never heard of
something before don't panic okay okay
so we're gonna do a numerical
integration example can everyone in the
back see on the screen okay yeah okay so
this is just a sketch of how you would
approximate what the error is for this
integral of f of X using like a left or
right rectangle so the basic idea is as
follows
so for one of those little rectangles
we're gonna integrate from X naught to X
naught plus Delta X the true area under
that curve for that Delta X is the
integral of f of X DX right we have some
real function that's doing some real
stuff in that interval and if we
integrated it it would be the true area
but we're going to approximate it by
just f of X naught times Delta X so what
I can do is I can say well how different
I can take my function f of X and I can
Taylor expand it about that left point f
of X naught and I can take all of these
terms in the Taylor series expansion and
I can integrate them out and I
essentially get a term that's my left
rectangle approximation plus Taylor
series error Delta x squared DF DX at X
naught that's all I'm gonna say about
how you compute the error or approximate
the error for these integrals it's very
similar to finite difference
differentiation you take a Taylor series
you plug it in at the right place and
your integral you cancel out terms with
the thing that you're approximating with
and
everything else's error that's all I'm
gonna say unless there's questions okay
all right so let's do some numerical
integration we're gonna call this test
you know int and the example that we're
going to integrate I think we'll just
integrate a sine function okay so we're
gonna take an interval a equals zero to
B equals ten with a DX of 0.1 okay zero
to ten increments the point one so it'll
be about 100 rectangles maybe one
hundred and one and then our function so
X is going to be a colon DX colon B it's
a vector from A to B in increments of DX
F is gonna be sine of X now again at
this point after line six we may
interpret this as being purely
data-driven there are no functions
anymore there's data vector X and data
vector F data-driven discovery is one of
these buzzwords that you can use to get
money from the government it doesn't
mean anything
so data-driven you'll here just come out
okay and then I'm gonna say N equals the
length of X because I just want to know
how many terms in my vector I have okay
and I can plot let's say plots X by F
cool I could say stares X by F that
gives me a little bit of a clearer idea
what we're actually going to be doing
we're gonna be adding up all of these
little rectangles squares let's just go
back to plot okay so let's just go
through left rectangle right rectangle
trapezoid then we'll move on okay
so left rectangle so I'm going to have
something called area one it's going to
start out equaling zero and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to step through
this function adding a
the areas of rectangles to my area to
area one okay so where do I start
what's the first thing I'm gonna do if I
need to add up a bunch of rectangles for
ya for all of the little rectangles in
my in my vector so for I equals 1 to N
minus 1 remember we're starting on the
left side of the integral so we're going
to start at index 1 and go to the end
minus 1 and we're gonna say area 1
equals area 1 plus DX times f of I
simple super simple and done okay that
was the left rectangle integration we
just integrated that yeah so again this
F is a vector of data the first element
of F is f of the first element of X the
second element of F is the I mean it's F
of 2 and that happens to be my function
evaluated at X of 2 yeah okay so I can
run that let's try right rectangle area
let's not call this area 1 let's call
this area left rectangle and area right
rectangle okay same thing for but what's
my new index gonna be it could be two to
end I could do one to n minus one that's
fine but I'd have to take F of I plus
one so let's just do for I equals to two
n because now we're starting right and
our first rectangle we're going to
measure the point to the right of that X
and we're going to go all the way to the
end of the data set and area are our
equals area are our plus DX times f of I
because my index now starts one later
and ends one later
okay that was it right rectangle rule
done should we be running these and
seeing what our answers are probably
okay area left rectangle predicts it's
1.86
area right rectangle predicts it's 1.81
so they're close but that's actually
pretty bad error right that's like two
percent error that's not acceptable okay
so let's do trapezoidal rule trapezoidal
integration okay so what do I do for
trapezoidal integration so n is the
length of my whole vector F how many
little rectangles do I have n minus one
so I'm gonna say okay area trap TZ
equals zero I'm gonna say for I equals
one to n minus one because I'm going to
go through for all of my rectangles
that's how I read this for all of my
rectangles I want to add up the
trapezoidal area of each of those
rectangles sorry they're not rectangles
they're DX's they're trapezoids for all
of my trapezoids I'm gonna add up that
trapezoid plus not Texas TZ okay what's
the area of my trapezoid what's the area
of my eighth trapezoid okay
DX over two times the first rectangle
plus the second rectangle right the
first height plus the second height I've
already added multiplied by DX so this
is f of I plus F of I plus one right
okay and when I run this I should get
area left left rectangle area right
rectangle and then area trapezoid should
be what somewhere in between okay one
point in fact it should be almost
exactly the average of the two not
exactly but almost exactly the average
of the two so good that makes sense it's
one point eight three seven five makes
sense
if I wanted to know how well I was doing
and how accurate these are what would I
actually do how would I get more
accurate predictions of these integrals
smaller DX okay so let's just make this
way way smaller GX equals 0.001 so this
is an incredibly small DX and so now our
area trapezoid our area left rectangle
area right rectangle and area trap Z
should be almost exactly the same but
notice that this is almost exactly what
my trapezoidal area was for a DX of 0.1
so my DX 2.1 trapezoidal integration was
really nailing it it was doing very very
good even with a coarse DX because it's
a second order accurate scheme okay okay
last thing on this example I should
actually tell you the way you would
really code this using the function trap
Z because that's how you would really do
it so doc trap Z okay so trap see
there's two different ways you can call
this you can say trap Z of X comma F my
X points and my function evaluated
points or I can just give it trap C of
the function evaluated points of F and
this is kind of assuming the fix to
Delta X so if I give it a trap C of X
comma F then technically I actually
don't need to give it uniformly spaced
Delta X points because it can compute
the area of one trapezoid with a 1 Delta
X the area of another trapezoid with
another Delta X and so on and so forth
that makes sense these Delta X's don't
have to be the same for trapezoidal
areas I can compute those trapezoidal
areas for any Delta X and as long as I
know the X spacing I know what my Delta
X is for each of those trapezoids okay
so that's the one we're going to use so
we're just gonna say area three area
four equals trap Z
XCOM s done 1.83 9/11 exactly the same
thing we got before so this is how you
would actually do it in MATLAB this is
like trap C or you could say area for
equals DX times trap Z of F if you don't
specify X it just assumes that they're
spaced one apart and so I'm going to
multiply it by DX afterwards same answer
I could do something crazy with the
Claude command I could create a spline
let's see
area Simpson equals this might be a
disaster quad of @x spline of how does
my spline work X in X dummy X comma F
comma X dummy from A to B I'll put this
online I'm not going to explain what I'm
doing
quad takes in a function not a vector I
have vectors of data so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to create a function
of a dummy variable X that evaluates a
spline that's built on my two data
vectors I have my data X in my data F
and I'm going to build a spline using
the spline command and I'm gonna wrap
that with a function so that now it's a
function of X if you tell me an X I'll
tell you the spline evaluated on my data
at that point X and now quad can
integrate that function from A to B this
will be way more accurate if it doesn't
crash yes it works all right and it
totally nails it okay this is the one
line integration it's fourth order
accurate it's the best thing you can do
okay that's all I want to say about
integration I went too far already any
questions about the code so far okay I
expect you to know much much more about
numerical differentiation and numerical
simulations of Odie's these are way more
important to me the numerical
integration but this is still important
stuff to know chances are you'll add up
things in your career and you want to
know like the good ways to add things up
okay
okay good so that's a nice segue into
numerical integration of vector fields
so when I say a vector fuel how many of
you know what I'm talking about how many
of you don't know raise your hands if
this is a confusing word vector field
vector fields can be confusing it was a
little kits still confusing so your
ordinary differential equation X dot
equals f of X f of X is a vector field
it gives you a vector X dot for every
point X that you can evaluate okay so
for me an ordinary differential equation
is synonymous with a trajectory in a
vector field it means the same thing any
time you hear me say vector field
I mean OTE okay so if I have some X dot
equals f of X then F is a vector field
it literally determines a vector DX DT
for every point in space X if this is a
field of vectors like if you go to a
wheat field it looks like a vector field
and you could integrate like what a
particle would do in that vector field
that's an ordinary differential equation
or you could go to a potential field pot
fields are great vector fields okay
in general F might be really nasty and
nonlinear but oftentimes we're gonna
have X dot equals a X and we should at
this point know that the solution is e
to the ATX naught and we know how to
solve this using eigenvectors and
eigenvalues and we know how to
understand the geometry of this
linearized differential equation and so
we're interested not in obtaining a
numerical solution to our differential
equation we can we can compute the the
analytic closed form solution for linear
systems but we really
do anything by hand for these nasty
nonlinear systems we can only do very
very simple things so in our examples
right we would take this system and we
find all of the fixed points and then we
linearize about the fixed points and
then we'd solved this for those
linearizations but I was kind of
cheating for most nonlinear differential
equations you can't even solve for the
fixed points this function is so nasty
you don't know when at zero or it's high
dimensional so you don't know when it's
zero this is a really big problem you
don't even know in general where your
fixed points are for a really complex
nonlinear OD e so you can't do any of
the things we talked about the only
thing you can do is pick an initial
condition X naught and try to see where
it goes
numerically okay so that's what we're
going to do for the next four five
lectures today Friday the next four
lectures so we're interested in
numerically obtaining a trajectory so we
want X naught and then we want to know
what is x1 exited you know the later
time we want to know x2 and x3 and dot
dot all the way up to X n so in my
really nasty nonlinear vector field
right I have all of these vectors maybe
this is where I live this is X and this
is my vector field so for example maybe
this is the fluid velocity field in the
Gulf of Mexico and X naught is where a
big blob of oil got dumped okay I should
have drawn my vector field in blue and
my oil in black now my oil is going to
be in red so this is a blob of oil in
the middle of the Gulf of Mexico this is
a vector field and by the way it also
depends on time all of these arrows
change in time with wind and with the
Sun load and with the currents so really
this whole vector field is changing in
time
and this is my little X naught and what
I want to do is numerically find out
where it is at x1 and then where it is
at x2 and then where it goes at x3 and I
want to integrate this trajectory of
this oil blob and figure out where it's
gonna go so it makes sense that's what I
mean by a vector field it's a time and
spatially varying vector field could be
really nasty and the only thing we can
do is figure out where trajectories go
and a trajectory is a set of discrete
points of where that particle is at
different times X at time 0 X at time 1
time 2 10-3 time n okay okay and we've
already seen how to do this I kind of
hinted at what we're gonna do in the
last lecture we're going to use finite
difference approximations for X dots and
we're going to get some kind of an
iteration scheme so that if I know X K
at time K I can tell you what X at time
k plus 1 is okay let's do that so this
is all based on our finite difference
derivatives ok so what is kind of my
first reasonable approximation for X dot
using the finite difference derivatives
what have we been doing in the last
class X dot is approximately sorry this
is DX DT so this is X at time T plus
Delta t minus X at time T divided by
delta T but I'm going to call what I
really want is XK dot is going to be X
at time k plus 1 minus X at time K
divided by delta T so we're going to see
what I did here like I don't want it to
be in terms of some generic time I want
like just I want to evaluate this at
discrete points in time time K time k
plus 1 so I take X at time k plus 1
minus X at time K divided by delta T
that's an approximately XK dot the case
derivative of sorry the time derivative
of X at time K and this based on our
differential equation is equal to f of X
K right that's what our differential
equation is X dot equals f of X and this
has to be true at all times K at all
indices K ok so we multiply both sides
by delta T and add XK and we get this
nice iteration scheme XK plus 1 equals
XK plus delta T times f of xk this is
such an important formula that it's
named after one of the greatest
mathematicians who ever lived
this is called forward euler he would
probably be embarrassed because this is
one of the most unstable and inaccurate
schemes to integrate a vector field
but it's also one of the most important
because we can really understand
everything about this this is kind of
the prototype for analyzing how stable
and accurate a numerical method will be
this is how we think about things like
stability and error so stability meaning
does this trajectory do anything like
what my actual solution does and does it
get more close as I make delta T smaller
okay any questions about what I wrote
down here and how I derived it this is
super duper important I want us to
remember this equation and if X dot
equals a times X so if f of X equals a
times X if my differential equation is
linear then I get a slightly kind of
easier version of this I say XK plus 1
equals XK plus delta T times a XK
and that's the same as identity matrix
plus delta-t a times XK XK is just
identity matrix times XK is it ok with
everyone that this X sub K is itself a
vector right X could be a vector of all
of the things I care about my position
in the oil field in X and y and z and at
every new time K I have a new x and y
and z ok so X itself could be a vector
and this this forward Euler iteration
just tells me if I know it my position
at time K I can get my position at the
next time k plus 1 by multiplying with
this matrix identity matrix plus delta T
times a we can program this in MATLAB
and it will follow our solution this
will approximate the actual solution e
to the a T so I'm gonna box these these
are super important these are called
forward Euler methods this is kind of
general this is specific for a linear
system not great stability not very
stable or accurate but it's a really
good prototype because we can really
understand everything about this system
we know what the solution is for a
linear system and we can compare that
solution with what we get when we
iterate this equation ok
so if I wanted to do something like
forward Euler but I wanted it to be more
accurate and more stable any guesses or
thoughts on how I might do that so I
have this type of formula this is where
we started
I could try something like a central
difference turns out that's not going to
help me much
actually that would help you but it's a
little complicated so what we're going
to do is instead of using this forward
difference we're going to try to use a
backwards difference and get an implicit
scheme so notice that this is entirely
explicit meaning if you give me x @k I
just multiply it by a matrix and I get
XK plus 1 this is like exactly what we
want numerically because matrix
multiplication is easy the next scheme
we're going to come up with is not as
nice to implement in a computer but it's
more accurate
okay so for this one what we're gonna
say is we're gonna take XK plus one
minus XK over delta T but we're gonna
say this is equal to XK plus 1 dot so
this is the backward difference scheme
at time k plus 1 right at time k plus 1
I'm looking backward in time to get my
approximation for the derivative so this
is backward difference and that's equal
to f of XK plus 1 now I still want to
solve for XK plus 1 in terms of XK I
still want this iteration so that when I
know XK I can get XK plus 1 and so I'm
going to multiply both sides by delta T
at XK I'm basically going to try to
collect all of the XK plus ones on one
side and all of the X K's on the other
and so I'm gonna get this kind of a mess
so I get XK plus 1 equals XK plus Delta
t F of XK plus 1 so this is why I'm
calling this implicit because I still
want to solve for XK plus 1 but I don't
have all of my XK plus ones on one side
where if I know XK I can just multiply
it by something and get the answer I
actually would have to solve using some
kind of an optimization or some kind of
gradient search for XK plus 1 at every
time step so this is an implicit
function of XK plus 1 this is called
implicit oiler this one boiler would be
happier with except it's really slow so
this one is better stability but XK plus
1 is
is implicit implicitly defined so that
makes sense the difference between
implicit versus explicit like implicit
means it's a pain in the ass to get it
like there's no good way of getting XK
plus one out of this you have to think
really hard to find out the XK plus one
that solves this equation okay but this
has much better error property well in
that area it has better stability
properties it's much more stable for a
linear system you actually can do stuff
so it for X dot equals ax will do the
same thing we're going to take the
special case of a linear dynamics we're
gonna say okay well XK plus 1 equals XK
plus delta-t a XK plus 1 this is still
implicit but now what can I do to solve
for XK plus 1
so it makes sense why we want to solve
for it XK plus 1 like we have this
numerical scheme I know X naught and so
I want X 1 as a function of X naught and
I want X 2 as a function of X 1 I want
XK plus 1 as a function of XK so I'm
going to bring all of my XK plus ones
over and then I'm going to invert
whatever matrix is on that side so I'm
going to say ok well this is like an
identity minus delta t a times xk plus 1
equals xk and now i can invert this
matrix sometimes not always but often
times i can invert this and I get
identity minus delta T a inverse X K so
these are my two implicit euler's
schemes taking a matrix inverse is not
as nice as just multiplying two matrices
like this is more expensive than just
multiplying i plus delta t a by a vector
this is very very expensive okay so I'm
not claiming that these are good methods
of numerical integration they are
important they're important because we
can directly analyze whether or not
they're stable and what their error is
for systems that we know the answer to
like X dot equals a times X and this
basic idea of using a finite difference
derivative to then cook up an iteration
scheme for our our trajectory this is
the basis of all numerical integration
ok so really really good numerical
integrator is like Oh de 45 just find a
really fancy formula for XK plus 1 in
terms of XK based on very very similar
ideas ok so I don't want to go any
farther today I think this is like a lot
to take in in the next lecture what
we're
going to do is code these up and see
what they do on a spring mass damper
system where we know the answer then
we're gonna start taking systems linear
systems X dot equals ax where we know
the solution and we're going to manually
compute when these systems kind of
diverge from each other or when they
agree and how closely they agree for
different Delta T's before we go are
there any questions we got five more
minutes this is an entirely new topic
and this is super important like this is
where I want to get with this part of
the course is so that you know how to
numerically solve OD YZ and vector
fields so this is really important I
want any questions you have like this
would be a great time
okay well happy Halloween I'll see you
all on Monday